hey guys Jess McDonald mom's orientee
we're back for house of horrors and
today we're playing among the steak some
of you may remember we played this back
when it was just a demo for a
Kickstarter but now it's a full game and
people gave them money and they made a
thing and it came out in may of this
year are from cruel rights to ya rabbi
yeah so you can crawl faster than you
can stand she's important I love that
they have baby that's good man this is
how you cool and this is how you see how
you baby well oh my god I drama
clear-eyed bad baby she frightened me is
her fault two years okay I'm gonna eat
the whole thing oh man there's cake
physics I love this baby ah delicious oh
my god I bet she's a single mom and this
is my dad and the whole story is about
my abusive father hold it wait okay well
thats dark hey you answer skinny
yourself oh oh that little that's cool
that's adorable oh so good stuff i
meanwhile fahza mommy no mommy no oh
it's fair oh hahaha teddy bear teddy
he's gone the Chinese dealing you sure
yeah holy crap he sounds like Volga's I
mean it's heavy oh that's a little bitty
airy do you have like objectives I mean
no sides of two year old children have
much an objective in life let me like
get a job huh wow I fell oh thank you
teddy piece of [ __ ] you get it now oh
don't stand on my move
yeah I know look at this one oh you can
press f to hug your bear that is so cute
Oh Oh mommy no don't mock him mom not in
front of my friends you need to press f
to hold him join quick f him wait a mess
him oh my cribs movie full geez that's
creepy I like this there now okay Oh
wasn't you Barry yeah I think he's in
there teddy oh my god [ __ ] [ __ ] you go
first well the bear on the from the ball
report back okay we're pull back safe
journeys this is what we played in the
dinner isn't it but they made it scary
uh-oh
I don't care about you scariness hello
mommy mommy have arrived why is mommy
don't sleep what backs against the wall
he's just mommy hates just Bobby coming
back mommy mommy forgot to take her
shoes off when she came back inside
mother
oh I'm coming mummy don't worry what is
this what is your the beer wow there's
an infantry very good yeah special 13
says finding memories this has never
been done in a game before is that looks
like a seesaw primitive catapult don't
close bear uh-huh an abandoned
playground it must be a way to nudge it
off yeah maybe you have to oh there you
go it's a strong baby how many of these
things do they want us to collect
absolutely huh
alright what I think I got to put the
owls in that I'm weird puzzle piece type
things come on a little one get up lazy
eat this um the thing looks like
catapult oh yeah I don't need one more
yes Alex promising holes are very creepy
and I would not go in there yep that
seems about right everything's fine
Teddy if you could buck up and stop
whinging like a little [ __ ] that'd be
great because you're making it scarier
than me karma made of magical stars and
dreams it's true oh right beverage sweet
rainbow road I do you best thing there
you keep saying that but an endless
things are a little bit case I believe
you Teddy telling me you should be
scared you should be scared doesn't make
if me scared Oh kill nope it's something
else kitty oh you you can die in this
game there you go treat switch oh oh my
goodness that's cool
oh I don't want go in the water us for
sure nope Sam the water come at the
house of waris tape Adam
she's definitely adults arguing like I
swear that's all the more I think that's
gonna do I have something to do with
that I think it's what scary bits the
atmosphere yeah it's it's it's more of
an animist like oh I did it again you
know I keep saying that do you think
lives it's losing it it's just like
daylight tell me to be scared yeah just
like daylight the girl she was like what
was that yeah Isis had me like and it
just didn't have any contest it's like
this i made like cuz and he loses his
like I don't trust him cuz he keeps
saying be quiet and then like oh [ __ ]
that was scary did she become a banshee
by drinking from the well ok it's a good
tutor was bitching about it I'll bangs
here and I'm gonna go in here cuz that
was creepy others for prints [ __ ]
hell the noise is terrifying yeah stupid
game you don't have to be scared
I hit she's God
I came out of it scary [ __ ] oh look
it's literally the monster own to bed
she been not being here come back over
here why don't we piss her off more by
like lifting the water out of the world
that she drank well that [ __ ] can [ __ ]
right off [ __ ] off [ __ ] off [ __ ] off
[ __ ] off bra Thank You [ __ ] about you
I'm walking this direction whether you
want me to or not oh there it is the key
ah good ah set pieces coming setting
scares coming
pro FAFSA I'll quit another window skit
oh right you can hear coming the trap
that is terrible I got shook up I didn't
miss you coming to us okay no one look
behind us go go go before she gets it
quick I didn't expect to get grabbed I
thought it would just be like just like
fuzz out likes Linda
crow foster baby
I think we should hurry up thunders I'm
just trying to add fresh so it's working
i'm at about me that was a good one oh
good one can you see my face in the
[ __ ] thing ok I'm climb out the whole
I understand you need to explain the
metaphor that story to me twice I
thought you would comment on them to us
scary do you happen to us we died like
600 a meaning if you'd like to see us
finish among sleep or outlast DLC or if
you want a whole other game let us know
down in the comments or you can write to
us on either about Twitter's um yeah
thanks for joining us again this week
thanks everyone will be back next week
good job by everyone